This lecture is a summary of this whole
course.
First, let's revisit the topics that we
covered in this course.
In the beginning, we talked about the
natural language processing and how it
can enrich text representation.
We then talked about how to mine
knowledge about the language, natural
language used to express what's
observed in the world of text data.
And in particular, we talked about how
to mine word associations.
We then talked about how to analyze
topic syntax, how to discover topics,
and analyze them.
This can be regarded as knowledge about
the oberved of the world, and then we
talked about how to mine knowledge
about the observer and particularly
talk about how to mine opinions and do
sentiment analysis.
And finally, we talked about the text
based prediction, which has to do with
predicting values of other real world
variables based on text data.
And in discussing this, we also
discussed the rule of non-text data which
can contribute to additional predictors
for the prediction problem and also it
can provide a context for analyzing
text data.
And in particular, we talked about how
to use context to analyze topics.
So,
here are the key high-level takeaway
messages from this course.
I'm gonna go over each of these major
topics and point out what are the key
takeaway messages that you should
remember.
First in NLP and text representation,
you should realize that NLP is
always very important for any text
applications because it enriches text
representation the more NLP, better
text representation we can have and this
further enables more accurate knowledge
discovery, to discover deeper knowledge
buried in text.
However, the current state of the art
of natural language processing is still
not robust enough, and so as a result,
the robust text mining
technologies today tend to be based on
word representation and tend to rely a
lot on statistical analysis, as we
have discussed in this course. You may
recall we mostly used word based
representations, and we've relied a lot
on statistical techniques,
on statistical learning techniques
particularly.
In Word Association Mining and
analysis,
the important points are first are we
introduced the two concepts for two
basic plan complementary relations of
words, paradigmatic and syntagmatic
relations.
These are actually very general
relations between elements in any
sequences. If you take it as meaning
elements that occur in similar context
in the sequence and elements that tend
to co-occur with each other and
these relations might also be
meaningful for other sequences of data.
We also talked a lot about the text
similarity when we discuss how to
discover paradigmatically relations, we
compare their context of words,
discover words that share similar
contexts. At that point that we talked
about, representing text data with a
vector space model, and we talked about
some retrieval techniques such as BM25
for measuring similarity of text and
for assigning weights to terms, TF-IDF
weighting, etc.
And this part is well connected to text
retrieval.
There are other techniques that can be
relevant here also.
The next point that is about the co-
occurrence analysis of text and we
introduced some information theory
concepts such as entropy, conditional
entropy and mutual information.
These are not only very useful for
measuring the co-occurrences of words,
and they're also very useful for
analyzing other kind of data, and
they're useful for example for feature
selection in text categorization as
well.
So this is another important concept to
know.
And then we talked about the topic mining and
analysis and that's where we introduced
the probabilistic topic model.
We spend a lot of time to explain the
basic topic model PLSA in detail.
And this is also the basis for
understanding LDA, which is a
theoretically more appealing model.
But we did not have enough time to
really go in depth in introducing LDA.
But in practice, PLSA seems as
effective as LDA, and it's simpler
to implement.
It's also more efficient.
In this part we also introduce some
general concepts that would be useful
to know.
One is generating model and this is a
general method for modeling text data
and modeling other kinds of data as
well.
And we talked about the maximum likelihood
estimator and the EM algorithm for solving
the problem of computing maximum
likelihood estimator.
So these are all general techniques
that tends to be very useful in other
scenarios as well.
Then we talked about the text
clustering and text categorization.
Those are two important building blocks
in any text mining application systems.
In text clustering we talked about the,
how we can solve the problem by using a
slightly different than mixture model
than the probabilistic topic model.
And we then also briefly reviewed some
similarity based approaches
to text clustering.
In categorization, we also talked about
the two kinds of approaches.
One is generative classifiers, they
rely on base rule to infer the
conditional probability of a category
given text data.
In particular, we introduced Naive
Bayes in detail.
This is a
practical, useful technique for a lot of
text categorization tasks.
We also briefly introduce some
discriminative classifiers,
particularly logistical regression K
nearest neighbor and SVN.
There also very important that they are
very popular and they're very useful
for text categorization as well.
In both parts we also discussed how to
evaluate the results, and evaluation is
quite important because if the measures
that you use don't really reflect the
utility of the method, then it would
give you misleading results.
So it's very important to get
evaluation right and we can talk the
about evaluation of categorisation in
detail with a lot of specific measures.
Then we talked about the sentiment
analysis and opinion mining, and that's
where we introduced sentiment
classification problem.
And although it's a special case of
text categorization, but we talked about
how to extend or improve the text
categorisation method by using more
sophisticated features that would be
needed for sentiment analysis.
We did the review of some commonly used
the complex features for text analysis
and then we also talked about how to
capture the order of these categories
in sentiment classification, and in
particular we introduced the ordinal
logistical regression.
Then we also talk about latent aspect
rating analysis.
This is unsupervised way of using a
generated model to understand the
review data in more detail.
In particular, it allows us to
understand the decomposed ratings of reviewer
on different aspects of the
topic.
So given text reviews with overall
ratings, the method would allow us to
infer the ratings on different aspects.
And it also allows us to infer the
reviewers latent
weights on these aspects on which
aspects are more important to the
reviewer, can be reviewed as well, and
this enables a lot of interesting
applications.
Finally, in the discussion of text
based prediction, we mainly talked
about the joint mining of text and non
text data as they are both very
important for prediction.
And we particularly talked about how text
data can help non text data and vice
versa. In the case of using non text
data to help the text data analysis,
we talked about the contextual text
mining.
We introduce the contextual PLSA as a
generalization or generalized model of
PLSA to allow us to incorporate
context variables such as time and
location and this is a general way to
allow us to review a lot of interesting
topical patterns in text data.
We also introduced the net PLSA.
In this case we use social network or
network in general of text data to help
analyzing topics.
And finally we talked about how time
series data can be used as context to
mine, potentially causal topics in text
data.
Now in the other way of using text to
help,
to help interpreting patterns discovered
from non text data,
we did not really discuss
anything in detail but just provide the
reference, but I should stress that
that's actually very important
direction to know about
if you want to build a practical text
mining systems, because understanding
and interpreting patterns is quite
important.
So this is a summary of the key
takeaway messages.
And, I hope these would be very useful
to you for building any text mining
applications or doing further study of
these algorithms and this should
provide a good basis for you to read
Frontier Research papers
to know about more advanced algorithms
or to invent new algorithms yourself.
So to know more about this topic, I
would suggest you to look into other
areas in more depth.
And during this short period of time of
this course, we could only touch the
basic concepts, basic principles of
text mining and we emphasize the
coverage of practical, useful
algorithms, and this is at the cost of
covering some more advanced algorithms
only briefly, or in many cases we
omitted the discussion of a lot of
advanced algorithms.
So to learn more about this subject,
you should definitely and learn more
about the natural language processing,
because this is the foundation for all
text based applications.
The more NLP you can do, the better
representation of texts that you can
get and then the deeper knowledge you
can discover.
So this is very important.
The second area that you should look
into is statistical machine learning
and
these techniques are now the backbone
techniques for not just text analysis
applications, but also for NLP.
A lot of NLP techniques are nowadays
actually based on supervised machine
learning.
So they are very important
because they are key to also
understanding some advanced NLP
techniques and naturally they would
provide more tools for doing text
analysis in general.
Now,
a particularly interesting area called
Deep Learning has attracted a lot of
attention recently.
It has also shown promise in many
application areas, especially in speech
and vision, and it has been applied to
text data as well.
So, for example, recently there has
been work on using deep learning to do
sentiment analysis to achieve better
accuracy, and so that's one example of
advanced techniques that we weren't
able to cover.
But that's also very important.
And the other area that has emerged in
statistical learning is the word embedding
technique where they can learn vector
representation of words and then these
vector representations would allow you
to compute the similarity of words.
As you can see, this provides directly
a way to discover potentially
paradigmatically relations of words and
results that people have got so far
are very impressive.
That's another promising technique that
we did not have time to touch.
But of course, whether these new
techniques would lead to practical use
for techniques that work much better
than the current technologies,
is the open question that has to be
examined.
And no serious evaluation has been done
yet in, for example, examining the
practical value of word embedding other
than word similarity based evaluation.
But nevertheless, these are advanced
techniques that surely will make impact
in text mining in the future.
So it's very important to know more
about these.
Statistical learning is also key to
predictive modeling, which is very
crucial for many big data applications.
We did not talk about that predictive
modeling component, but this is mostly
about the regression or categorization
techniques, and this is another reason
why statistical learning is important.
We also suggested you to learn more
about data mining, and that's simply
because general data mining algorithms
can always be applied to text data
which can be regarded as a special case
of general data.
So there are many applications of data
mining techniques in particular, for
example, a pattern discovery would be
very useful to generate a interesting
features for text analysis.
Recently, information network mining
techniques can also be used to analyze
text information network.
So these are all good to know in order
to develop effective text analysis
techniques.
And finally, we also recommend you to
learn more about the text retrieval
information retrieval or search
engines.
And this is especially important if
you're interested in building practical
text data application systems.
And a search engine would be essential
system component in any text based
applications, and that's because text
data are created for humans, to us to
consume.
So humans are at the best position to
understand the text data.
It's important to have human in the
loop in a big text data applications.
So it can in particular help text
mining systems in two ways.
One is to effectively reduce the data
size from a large collection to a small
collection with the most relevant text
data that only matter for the
particular application.
So the other is to provide a way to
annotate it, to explain patterns, and
this has to do with knowledge
provenance.
Once we discover some knowledge, we
have to figure out whether the
discovery is really reliable and so we
need to go back to the original text
that are verified and that's when
the search engine is very important.
Moreover, some techniques and
information retrieval, for example BM
25, vector space and language models,
also very useful for text data mining.
We only mention some of them, but if
you know more about the text retrieval,
you'll see that there are many
techniques that are useful.
Another technique that's useful is
indexing technique that enables quick
response of search engine to users
query and such techniques can be very
useful for building efficient text
mining systems as well.
So finally I want to remind you of this
big picture for harnessing big text
data that I showed you at the very
beginning of the semester.
So in general, to build a big text data
application system, we need two kinds
of techniques, text retrieval and text
mining.
And text retrieval as I explained, is to help
convert the big text data into a small
amount of most relevant data for a
particular problem, and can also help
providing knowledge prominence, help
interpreting patterns later.
Text mining has to do with further
analyzing the relevant data to discover
the actionable knowledge that can be
directly useful for decision making or
many other tasks.
So this course covered text mining, and
there's a companion course called text
retrieval and search engines that
covers text retrieval.
If you haven't taken that course, it
would be useful for you to take it,
especially if you are interested in
building a text application system and
taking both courses would give you a
complete set of practical skills for
building such a system.
So in very end I just would like to
thank you for taking this course.
I hope you have learned useful
knowledge and skills in text mining and
analytics.
As you see from our discussions, there
are a lot of application opportunities
for this kind of techniques, and there
are also a lot of open challenges, so I
hope you can use what you have learned
to build a lot of useful applications
to benefit the society and to also join
the research community to discover new
techniques for text mining and analytics.
Thank you.